well I wouldn't call Oprah and I close
friends you know we she's been really
helpful to me and I have so much respect
for her I've had the opportunity to
spend time with her a few times and I
think she's you know one of the most
amazing individuals in the world truly
she's done so much good for the world
and she's been so successful and and she
represents herself and and frankly she
represents black people really well you
know she she's someone that we are
really proud of and I'm proud to be
associated with her I'm proud that she
loves my music enough to recommend it to
my to her fans and it means something
and I think she's a great example of
someone who has been very careful with
her brand and has a name that actually
means something that when she associates
herself with something it carries weight
and how many people can say that it's
really impressive and I'm proud that
she's decided that my music is something
that she really loves and that she finds
worth recommending people
you guys influence on global culture I
go to South Africa and Oprah's big there
I go to Europe and people have seen me
on Oprah there i go to my good friend
his mother's from pakistan she sees me
on TV there you know through oprah and
she's effluent to everywhere but clearly
she has influence here in the States I
mean I don't need to state the obvious
but her book club obviously makes a huge
difference a specific artist when they
go on and perform there they'd the
record sales go up mine go up when i go
on their show it means something to be
one of her favorite things or something
that she wants to promote to the people
it really does make a difference and
that comes from her being known for good
taste known for integrity and known for
being cautious about how to use it
what you would think actually because of
so many different forms of media so many
disparate ways that people get
information nowadays that the influence
of one person would actually be kind of
diffused in a certain way but for some
reason Oprah has maintained that power
even as people are watching less TV and
you know paying attention to the
internet more even as people are getting
their entertainment in all kinds of ways
they still listen to what she says and
part of it may have to do with her
audience and maybe they're her audience
is still kind of majority you know women
that stay home during the day and so for
them you know if the TV is on and
Oprah's on she's going to have some
influence on them and why not I think
she uses her influence for good
you